il ya beaucoup de choses sur vous dans
la presse française vanessa
bah oui ce lot of england presse people
française et c'est vrai il ya beaucoup
de choses alors on va vérifier si les
rumeurs sont vraies ou pas est-ce que
c'est vrai que vous avez été approché
pour jouer dans la saga twilight non non
c'est pas vrai d'accord donc ça c'est
une connerie très bien est ce que c'est
vrai que vous êtes mariés dans le plus
grand secret avec votre compagnon austin
butler non bagués arrivent nouri ça
rassure jean michel ce que sachez que ce
garçon est très amoureux de vous il y
avait c'est vrai d'ailleurs on fera un
jeu dans un instant je vous le dis avec
jean michel mr et on espère que
jean-michel va bien tombé est ce que
c'est vrai qu'entre selena gomez la
fiancée de justin bieber et vous c'est
pas le grand amour
parce que c'est vrai on est de très bons
amis
schlatter jay leno à bosser votre pote
on adore elle est vraiment très géniale
et très belle il ya des gens beaucoup je
peux pas blairer - allez ça pas moi jour
sur la cour sur la vie de ma mère que tu
aimes bien et dont elle est dans la
merde tu avais raison
madiha apparemment et bayer qui avait
pas ma mère est ce que c'est vrai est ce
que c'est vrai que zac effron votre ex
est devenu quel con c'est vrai est vrai
que zac le front il est devenu gay
paraît-il c'est vrai ou pas c'est des
rumeurs aussi horrible comme d'humeur
non mais c'est pas du tout ça
franchement c'est ça peut être c'est
très bien aussi bas c'est vrai nom c'est
une rumeur
ils sont très bons mais même moi j'ai
envie de peut-être tête dont les
audiences
ça ne m alors regardez qui m'appelle
s'écrivent adams qui m'appelle kev adams
qui m'appelle on dirait que tu sur pied
pour ovale à on va lui répond week end
tu section des missions kev
qu'est-ce qui se passe non mais vanessa
léon ballat
frère tu peux pas être sur tous les
dossiers non plus là c'est gallas qui
veut parler à madame c'est un humoriste
français very very big un doublon mdina
tue-tête you know
je ne connais pas mais est ce vraiment
fauteuil super mais bien assez ce à
celui sa lumière on a sa photo et ouais
parle lui de seconde et on n'a pas le
temps l'émission tu as dit second album
studio tu actually ou twitter mais damon
[Applaudissements]
ces cancers déjà sur twitter dit oui
j'ai plus oui oui hélas view et love you
very much et m
[Applaudissements]
mais moi dix mois et votre numéro
tu as vu comme je l'avais mis sur un
plateau salle à aller je t'embrasse
tiens voilà en tout cas elle est très
très sympathique vraiment vanessa noir
sympathy cole overs effective non mais
vous avez vu comment ils jouent bien le
jeu
on est très très heureux de vous avoir
[Musique]